Hôm nay, người bà đường hông bệnh sợi anh yếp ngày 19.
Đã tiến hành một chiến dịch không kích quý mồn lần trong đen.
Nhằm và cất cơ sở quân sự và hành nhân tại Iran,
chiến dịch của sự tham gia của mũi chiến nâu cơ,
nhằm đến có một tiêu chiến lược tại The Iran Arab Nhatans,
và nhiều khu đất khác.
Theo Ide, không một chiếm lại bố kỷ để được sự dùng trong chiến dịch,
bói sử dẫn hướng chính xác từ cuộc tình báo của Doisarine,
một trong những một tiêu trọng yếu là lọng và những hành nhân nước nạn ở Ává,
bố tình liy cá mùa có khả nâng sản xuân, bố tương niông,
cấm độ bố kỳ, mọi giối Iran Tinh mô đã chuyển đổi lọng và những ngày,
nhưng viễn Soren Cho rằng,
Té Iran của tình dữ lại tìm năng phát triển hảm nhân,
nhằm tạo xức hay bối phương tầy.
Hoài Ává,
các cuộc không tích cũng nhảm vào cơ sở gần Nhatans,
nơi chữa thiết bị và linh kiện của vụ chuviac vàng giáo Uran Yume,
và chế tạo đường đại hảm nhân.
Hìa đi Iran chứ đưa ra phản lưng chính thức,
nhưng chuyển thống nước này cho biết,
hệ thống phòng không đến được kích hoạt trăm sút thử dàng diễn xa của tấn công.
Chúng khi đó, một quan chứ quân sự Iran cho biết,
2 phần 3 số bệ phòng tên lửa đàn đạo của Iran đã bị phá hủy cho miếng chiến dịch.
Cầm đồng của tệ tích được theo dõi sát tình hình và kêu hỏi các bên kiến trế,
chẳng đại khu vực và vòng sói xung đột mới.